i've got to talk about the issue
that that everyone is most concerned
about this morning that would be the
slap heard round the world
no i did not watch the oscars last night
no you did not watch the oscars last
night no i don't think anyone watched
the oscars last night but we all saw
this trend and then we all tuned in for
this clip when chris rock made a joke
about will smith's wife's hair and will
smith got up and smacked him across the
face
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
[Applause]
it's javazone that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
oh wow
wow
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i james keep my wife's
name out
i'm going to okay
oh okay
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
okay all right well that's fine the
greatest night in the history of tv he
said chris rock recovers pretty well
here over what a joke about
jada smith's hair so jada smith has hair
loss she's losing her hair
apparently the medical condition is
alopecia some people have alopecia from
a very very young age and they don't
have any hair at all jada smith has had
hair her whole life but she now has hair
loss as she's getting older and
chris rock made a joke about this
and he said okay here's gi jane two
because in g.i jane demi moore has very
short hair
and will smith sort of laughed at this a
little bit and then he decided no and he
gets up and he smacks chris rock across
the face and
then starts screaming
there are so many angles to this story
i think though i have the least
conventional tank take so some people
think it was staged because the oscars
have been losing viewership for a decade
now and they wanted to get viewership
back up it doesn't look staged to me yes
it's a room full of actors it could have
been staged it seemed real
so i i don't think that's the case
i don't know that chris rock would have
agreed to it maybe he would have i don't
know i so i'm going with the assumption
that it was
real
the joke itself was pretty mild by
hollywood standards he was making a joke
that now she's got
very shortly cropped hair because she's
losing her hair jada smith could have
turned this into a kind of strong yes i
am woman hear me roar kind of moment
yeah i am gij and i'm a tough lady uh
but that that didn't happen
she was a fat she was offended okay
that's why it's fine to be offended on
behalf of your wife of course if your
wife is going to be in show business in
public life at an event where people
make these sorts of jokes then it seems
like that's kind of what you're signing
up for but okay will smith decides that
he's going to get up and defend his
wife's honor i actually have no problem
really with the slap is it an
overreaction probably is it a little
uh
unconventional it wasn't really called
for by the joke itself i'm not so sure
we can debate that i
i actually think we would live in a much
better culture if every time someone
insulted our wives even during an awards
show someone got up and just smacked him
across the face because it didn't look
like a punch to me it looked like a
corrective slap
sorry demand satisfaction slap right
across the face i think that's a good
thing more on that in one second first
though you've got to go to dealdash.com
knowles whether you're in the market for
a basic kitchen appliance or a luxury
upgrade to your old tv deal dash will
allow you to get the best deals on
whatever you're looking for dealdash
partners with brands of all sizes
wholesalers inventory liquidators when
these brands are stuck with excess
inventory that they can't sell dealdash
helps out by buying the excess lots and
then can pass on big savings to its
customers on brand new high quality
products dealdash has hundreds of
auctions daily on brand new items
ranging from tvs and laptops to tools
and kitchenware even cars with
guaranteed free shipping
ipads i kid you not ipads have sold for
33 dollars and 60 cents brand new cars
brand new cars have sold for less than a
thousand bucks you've got to check this
out in order to keep prices low deal
dash charges a small fee to place a bid
you can always buy the product at the
buy it now price and get the credits
back that you used in the auction then
reuse them in later auctions all
auctions start at zero dollars and
you've got a 90-day money-back guarantee
on your first bid pack do not be made a
victim with today's inflation head on
over right now to deal dash use promo
code knowles for an additional 100 free
bids when making your first bid pack
purchase and start bidding
dealdash.com now we live in this culture
where we're told that anyone's allowed
to say anything they want they can talk
about your wife they can talk about your
mother they can talk about your god they
can say whatever they want and you're
never allowed to go up and have a
corrective smack across the face and
it's because we've made an ideology out
of a complete distortion of what free
speech really is
the founding fathers were the great
defenders of free speech in history but
they would not have tolerated someone
insulting their wife or daughter or
mother they would have gotten up and
smacked them across the face and
probably dueled them to the death okay
so that i i actually think we would live
in a culture that was more dignified
more focused on honor if we could do
this the smack
what
will smith got wrong here is that he
then sat down in the chair and started
screaming profanities like a lunatic
keep my wife's name that's very
uncivilized
that is very
in the poor man i don't think it had
anything to do with chris rock's
joke i think will smith has been
publicly humiliated for years now by his
wife who is boasting on television about
how will smith is the biggest cuckold in
america and will smith has to just sit
there and take it
i don't i don't think it was the joke
about his wife that set will smith off i
think that was the straw that broke the
cuckold's back and he went out and he
took out all of his rage on the on the
men that his wife is bragging about
sleeping with he took it all out on poor
old chris rock chris rock total showbiz
professional
one takes the smack like a man barely
even flinches then goes on makes a
couple jokes this is the greatest night
in the history of tv and moves on
good for the oscars it finally got them
a little
a little
play but don't don't take the wrong
lesson don't take the wrong lesson from
this incident the right lesson is
if someone insults our wives and our
mothers and our daughters or whatever
and you give them a little corrective
smack i like that that's a good cult we
should we should develop that culture
but don't lose your cool don't lose your
temper temper and start screaming like a
maniac and using all sort of profanity
and make them bleep you out that
not very manly at all that's the most
important pressing issue today if you
look at twitter if you look at the news
if you look at what everyone's talking
about
and in a way it is we need it we want a
dignified culture of honor
i'm so glad you liked that clip now ring
the bell subscribe make sure you get the
notifications and also head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review if
you haven't watched it yet you've got to
watch fouchy unmasked the three-part
docu-series at dailywire.com we'll see
you there
[Music]
[Music]
you